the world is eagerly awaiting the
arrival of Britain's newest royal that's
Prince Harry and Megan Markel they are
another day closer to welcoming their
first child and I cannot wait to get
this news megan has gone from TV star
and philanthropist to duchess of Sussex
thank you very much but the quick
transition to royalty has drawn some
harsh scrutiny hi Harry
Thank You Megan to be my wife last
spring about 50 million people tuned in
to watch the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
say I do the treatment and of itself is
being able to be here and be with these
incredible women on the panel for many
Megan Marco an American biracial
divorcee symbolized a modern and
refreshing addition to the royal family
Harry and Megan have taken a different
approach to royal life earlier this
month the palace announced the couple's
plans for the upcoming arrival of their
firstborn would remain private that
means no pictures on the hospital steps
after the birth of their child a
tradition William and Kate and Harry's
parents have embraced the Sunday Times
reported this week that the Duke and
Duchess could live abroad in Africa for
three years offering them what the
newspaper calls a break from the UK
though very popular Markel has faced
heavy scrutiny the 37 year old has been
the target of online trolling racism and
rumors of growing tensions within the
royal family in an interview in February
markle's friends defended her they say
they wanted to stand up against the
global bullying and speak the truth
about our friend the royal family has
since announced new social media
community guidelines to create a safe
environment on the royal family social
media platforms CBS News contributor
that's Tina Brown covered the royal
wedding with us she's also the author of
the Dianna Chronicles so she knows his
royal family Tina good morning good
morning I remember we were on that
balcony we were one of the 50 million I
was standing there going Harry
the cake yeah that was quite a day
pretty good moment so a lot has happened
in the year too for Harry and Megan
she's gotten married she's moved she's
having a baby she certainly had been
under a microscope how do you think
she's handled what can be a very harsh
bottle I think she's done a great job
you know of coming into this immensely
difficult situation and when you
consider that when Diana came in she was
20 you know Megan is 36 an accomplished
celebrity already but what they all have
to deal with and what she's dealing with
are two-pronged Horrors one is the awful
gossiping feuding sneaky viper in
hissing courtiers of the different rival
camps and the other and the palace yeah
because Clarence house where Charles
lives you know hates and rivals and
competes like different TV shows all
competing with you out there right
they're really trying to come
protect Charles and Camilla I mean after
all he's gonna everyone forgets Charles
have gone over they are actually the
next in line yeah and then hairiest to
staffs and William and start staff
before they were together now they've
split apart because each needs their own
office no huge poor town here they're
now men of 30 they need have their own
offices with their own agendas they are
all kind of fighting and then there's
the Queen's lot that you know of course
is the big brother of it all and they
get the last say but a lot of hissy fits
and the second thing of course is the
press who have always believed the Royal
boys are theirs you know they felt very
protective about the whim Harry thing
but again these boys are not children
and you know they're not on that
tricycle is being protected yeah let's
start with they're no longer boys
because either no no boys and and so now
they've got their own agency and the
press don't like it they want them to
still be you know this they remember
them is it all vanity all of this
sniping and fighting or is there a real
something really at stake which is well
I mean what is at stake is is a kind of
is the spotlight and power shift I mean
poor Prince Charles had to be you know
wait for I mean he's all set he's now 70
you know and he's still the Prince of
Wales why doesn't the Queen step down
too you know she's 93 she won't stepped
out because she doesn't believe this is
about an office she thinks it's about an
incarnation she's not running for office
you know Queen will die in her bed as
the Queen she took an oath spent in
Westminster Abbey you know in all the
days of my life well you know would she
reign and that's the kind of woman that
she is kind of purse
we're all waiting for baby suspects
right waiting for baby so soon how are
those some of the traditions are
changing with them in terms of a royal
baby changing the game
well they've decided they don't want to
have any royal photograph on the step
you know all the snap has come outside
the hospital is that a positive to
people that it has really really angered
the press I'm not so sure that was the
greatest of moves in terms of the whole
perception and popularity but on the
other hand this is a very private event
she's allowed to do what she wants after
having a baby but it has definitely
alienated the press I think she could
have given them unlike their two minutes
and got into a car it would have been a
better karma at this particular moment
the fact they decided not to is
obviously a defiant gesture saying this
is our private act so that has
definitely upset people a lot the other
things that she's doing differently
having her own ob/gyn they're not the
Queen's you know to bus suited you know
sort of potentate I don't really yeah
she doesn't want the Queen's kinda team
which I get I mean Kate did do that
because Kate always is so perfect she
just did exactly what she was supposed
to do but Megan again she's an
independent woman of her own thinking
but she also heard your choice of your
gynecological for a brain use the word
defiant because they make the decision
that they want to have their picture
release away they want to could it be
that they're not in line for the throne
that they just want to do this very
differently no I think that really
entitled I but I think it's it's been
the reason for quite a lot of animosity
yeah you know she wanted a woman to
deliver her child which i think is great
I mean she's you know Diana got all the
same flak when Diana decided that her
her child was going to go you know to
this little school instead of being
homeschool all the rest she did what she
wanted to do she took she was the first
role to take her baby on a royal to her
you know and you know everybody then did
the same thing to her so she's just
moving the needle but just one night
what year is it work you know stress do
you think people are cheering them on
yes I mean what's incredible is of
course we now have the social media
metric which the rolls never had that's
going to add some more yeah you know
competitive issues around because you
know within five hours of them launching
their personal Instagram they've got 5.1
million followers turn the volume up to
ten and listen
Taylor Swift the haters are gonna hate
hey yeah we're just gonna shake it off
yes Tina thank you so good to have you
here celebrate I know you'll be back
I'll be back I know